all right andrea
andrea where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um originally from
fishtown born and raised
philadelphia yes um
my
two brothers
older than me they have a different
father
my mom left their father and got with my
dad
my dad was an addict and my mother
wasn't they both worked in the hospital
my mom was in a
rn and
at the time my dad was an orderly
and
uh i mean i never knew he was on drugs
because by the time he had stopped using
them i was uh five years old like my mom
had had enough
and he went out to
keswick somewhere in new jersey got
clean
so
and then my brothers stayed with their
dad so it was always me and my mom
growing up
we went from house to house
uh
at six years old um i was molested by my
mom's best friend's son he was 17
because they would watch me while my mom
was at work
and it took a year
because he would tell me that if i told
my mom that he would kill her
and thank god she came home from work
early one day and um
he had me and his little brother and
sister because he would make us do stuff
too
and when she was screaming my name he
hurried up and dressed me and put my
skirt and underwear on backwards
and she said she could see it in my face
and uh
you know questioned me and i finally
broke and sold
so
she got me treatment but by nine i was
still having like horrible panic attacks
and they put me on
collodipine
and um
i'm not gonna lie i i i like the feeling
like i didn't know if i like the feeling
or if i like that they stop the panic
attacks
but
as i got older
um i always hung around older people
a couple years older than me
because my brother
we're all four and a half years apart so
i
you know
the
the middle one i'm the youngest so my
middle brother
um you know i was always fascinated by
him and his friends so
i didn't actually hang with ben but i
hung with like an older group
and
you know that they would drink and
benzos i was already familiar with the
benzos from
the collodipine that they prescribed me
as a kid
i started abusing them
and i always was straight a student
in sports i played soccer i had you know
a scholarship down the line after high
school that i blew um
i played softball but like the weekend
games started getting harder to go to
because i would drink them it was first
it started out this is like a weekend
thing
and then um
like i was saying i got injured i was
playing in the tournament out in
bensalem
and i got injured and they took me to a
doctor but at the time they didn't know
he was a crooked doctor
and he prescribed me oxycontin
and
[Music]
the strongest milogram is annex
so
you know i was taking them as prescribed
not at first because the first day
started they made me sick because
you know i wasn't used to opiates
so um
over time you know i started building
the tolerance i did them for about two
years
and
maybe close to three
and uh
the fbi was watching them dea
and he got busted
so
uh
i was buying
them and um because when i would go to
him
i would
sell some because he would give me 120 i
would sell some buy some
i mean i would sell some keep some for
head stash
then i went to heroin
and uh there's a whole new game after
that
you know um
like
just
i
fighting with my family uh
knock him in home
got introduced to um
sex for money
and um
[Music]
my mom that's one thing she never put me
on the streets maybe for a day or two
in uh
2013
um
i got up for 20 some days
and got a phone
call i got a visit actually i talked to
my mom that day it was thanksgiving day
i told her i would call her later while
she was at families
and
before then i got a visit that she i'd
been asking to tech
and um
after that
i was homeless
lost my kids
and um
it pretty much
pushed me over the edge
because i never had that experience
like
um
you know she would like say
two days three days but
like i was always the person like
when i was running the streets and like
none of the girls had homes to go to
i would always take them to my mom's and
she would feed them and i would let them
shower and
give them clean clothes because i never
had to experience that
so
i would help people
and then once it happened to me
and like i said i was in jail when it
happened so i went to my mom's funeral
shackled and handcuffed
i was the only one in there no family
members were there to comfort me
um
i pretty much didn't believe it until i
seen it
and uh not too long after that
because when that had happened i had two
kids at the time that me and my mom
race together
and my brother took them two kids
how many children do you have
um
four
but one i gave up for adoption
so my brother had the two that my mom
had
and then
that third one went up for adoption
because
i was raped with her out there
um
also i didn't want to put more burden on
my mom which you know she was getting
older i didn't want to put more burden
on her with another baby
so when i had that fourth baby uh
i stayed clean
and
i uh
like i was really ready to do it
and um the whole time they were telling
me that they weren't going to take her
from me
i was in a woman against abuse shelter
with her
like not with her
but they approved her to come there
she was in the hospital two months
because i was on methadone you know why
i was pregnant by her when i was
pregnant with her because
before i found out i was pregnant i was
using
um
but beings i got clean and got on the
clinic you know the
social worker at the hospital
uh dhs like everybody was telling me i
was getting her and four hours before
she was discharged
the dhs worker called and said uh
you have somebody to take her right and
i'm like
take her
no i never planned on anybody taking her
because
like they told me that she was coming
with me
like
it got
approved i have everything she needs
and they were like well your brother has
your other two children right and i said
yeah and they said well do you want to
call him i said i don't have it in the
heart to call him i said if you want to
call him you can
so
uh
i've been at the hospital with the baby
and like
so you know while i'm waiting for a dhs
worker to um come up and pick her
um uh
you know my head's just going like
where is she going where is she going
i'm just like holding on to her for dear
life like holding a rocking her
and
when the lady walked in i just grabbed
her and saw to the floor and i'm crying
and i'm like can you at least tell me
where she's going and she said
oh i didn't tell you your brother agreed
to take her so like that was like the
world to me
because he only has one of his own
and now that made three of mine
and him and his wife had been together
since they were 12. they've never been
with anybody else
so and my mom had she
she had a messed up mom my mom had taken
her in when she was 12 her her mom
kicked her out my sister-in-law
who has my children so i know she's
great because she would watch me
when my mom was at work and you know
like i just knew she was great i knew my
kids were in great hands
and um
they never kept my kids from me
like if i called right now they would
put them on the phone with me
um
i do call but for the most part uh
i don't really uh go over because i want
to be able to be consistent
i don't want to be
in and out and hurt them more
than they already been hurt
so um
pretty much
uh
[Applause]
they
sold
sold the house right away
there was like
my bro my oldest brother just like
it was in fish town like he just sold it
pretty much for pennies just to get rid
of it
and um
you know
for like
six months i paid up
a front to stay in a room
and then like
of course money the rest of money i
bought clothes and blew on drugs
and
in between then
i've had clean time i've you know
i've been to rehab
and then recovery but it always ends up
the same thing you can only stay so long
and then it's like they three right back
to the streets
so um
you know
life on the streets is
rough
tell me about living on the streets in
kensington kensington oh
my god how long you been here
uh-huh how long you been here how long
have you been down there
um
i would say
on and off
five years because like i said i would
go to rehab
like recovery houses
but right now straight um
a little over
a year
um
actually
we were in um
okay some backtrack real quick me and my
girlfriend that your fiance
um
we've known each other from out there
and um
june
will be five years we met back up in
jail
and uh we got out like the we started
dating in jail
and
we got out about the same time
and um
you know we we would find
sometimes like
uh
people that would take us in for like
two months you know like
or like
shower
before the pandemic used to be able to
ride the train
all night
so we would just do that
and then
in
august we went to kirkbride
we got out in uh
went in all into august we got out
beginning october and then got on this
methadone clinic that we're on now
um so before methadone your drug was
uh
fentanyl
um
well xanax is still my drug but
it's more or less like my anxiety
because like i said they prescribed them
to me at 11 years old from when i was
molested so
it's like
i
if i'm around somebody that's even like
like
high tension person
like i get them like
uh i
i think it stems back from
being molested at a young age and like
from them giving me them
that
that's
what worked for me
um
so um
me and her
i had a friend that was he was my soccer
coach growing up so
for like
eight months what he would do is he
would lock us in
a utility closet it used to be a um
a bathroom like when the playground was
um
like open years ago
and so it had a toilet two sinks
and then they started using it as a
storage
closet for like soccer balls and all
but every night we would meet him there
at a
seven o'clock at night 7 30
and
he would bring us like some food we had
quilts and uh pillows in there and at
least like we had a toilet and like
two sinks that we could you know wash up
in and stuff
and uh we were in there for a good uh
eight months but on the weekends
because that was the only time you could
ride the train train and stay open all
night during the week
and even then sometimes we would stay
there
um
so he gave you a place to sleep yeah
he winded up having a heart attack
um
no strings attached no no strings
attached
he was just really
um like i said i played soccer for him
for about 10 years
and you know
he he just genuinely seemed like he's
the one that paid for me to go to my
mom's funeral from jail because that's
500
if you're you know
um and
my
brother was paying for the actual
funeral and it was unexpected like it
was an asthma attack it wasn't like we
were preparing for this
and it just so happened like a couple
months before she died
she switched her life insurance policy
so um
she none of it went through so like
everything
had to you know be paid cash
um
so like yeah
but like
what we try to do
is
um we'll go down like kensington during
the day
um whether
we boost
uh
whether we gotta do what we gotta do
you know to get
you know the money
for that then
that's what it is
but like i said we've had clean time um
like
she's always waitressed uh
i've laid carpet i've you know i've
i've worked too
when you know i get clean so when you
were when you were younger how old are
you now
i'll be 40 in october when you were a
younger girl did you have dreams of
doing something else with your life yeah
what do you want to do um
a
marine biologist
i went to seoul high school it's an
agriculture high school
so like it was either a veterinarian or
then i started getting more into marine
biology
and then when i got older uh
i wanted to operate heavy machinery
which
that
is still kinda
my um my plan
um
or to get into the drug field
and
i would like to kind of work with
adolescents so i can
share my story
so they don't have to go through what i
went through even if i can touch one
person
because
my biggest fear is my kids
getting on drugs
i mean my sister-in-law and my brother
don't use but
all three of my kids were
born addicted to methadone
because
i never knew i was pregnant
until you know so
i always got all methadone when i was
pregnant
there's addiction in your family
um with my dad with your dad yeah
did you feel like it was that or do you
think it was sexual abuse as a young
girl
that played a bigger part i think that
a lot of it stemmed from
i definitely believe um you know if they
condition they prove that it is
through you know um
my dad's mom was an alcoholic my dad was
pretty much
a
coke mess like he shot everything like i
said
he got clean when i'm six
and
now he uh
helps him minister anesthesia
and um i have a step brother who is
actually like the anesthesiologist
my dad had like
uh
a year or two to go left to be an
anesthesiologist but
um
he needed kidney transplant his from
drug abuse from back then
you know as he got older it started
messing with them
so right now like my goal
is
the pro the clinic that we're on right
now
is uh i'm gonna go back into rehab i'm
gonna do long term and then from there
i'm gonna either go to self
or they have this couple shelter
and
go from there
and you know
actually um
before i seen you
we were gonna go get dosed and
my dentist does walk-ins from um
10-2
i was going to go there but obviously i
could really use the money so i'll do
that tomorrow
and plus from the dentist we were going
to go down the prevention point i don't
know if you heard of that it's
a church um
in kensington
that like has case managers that can
help you like get in the shelters and
stuff like that
so uh
we had stopped there like 15 minutes
before we seen you
and it's
um administration day
so
um
because we were gonna go there from the
um
from the dentist
when you're not
finding housing through some kindness of
a friend or whatever
finding a shelter or whatever where do
you stay
a 30th street station
you just find a place to crash for the
night
uh yeah but i i leave kensington
too dangerous
uh
i just don't like how it's not even the
dangerous because
i've been around all that
it's
they
you can't get sleep like it's
then people
like
not
there's a shelter right up the street
and
half of the people that are in that
shelter they still sleep outside
because you're there you're they're
allowed out three days in a row so
they'll pop their head in
on the third day
so they don't lose their bed
and then
back off again which i
don't think that's fair because there's
people that really
like
want
to get into that shelter and
like for instance
me like
i
i want to go there and
get a job like that's why i was waiting
you know to get my teeth so you know i
can present a moment i go
you know i'm looking for a job and i
want them anyway
i had had them and i overdosed and uh
the emergency room
i guess took them out like to uh
put a tube in my throat because i was
breathing but i was breathing very
shallow
so when i got outside the hospital i
noticed that they weren't in so i went
right back in and was like can you get
my nurse from the emergency room and she
was like oh yeah they're back here while
the cleaning lady had came
at that time and trashed them
so i had to switch my insurance and now
um
i was there uh
friday just passed and she told me to
come in
monday tuesday
like whatever and that she still should
have my own molding because i told her
that i liked the first set that she did
and you know i just really wanna uh
i'm i'm i'm just sorry i'm i'm gonna get
i'm ready to get my life together again
it gets depressing after a while doesn't
it
it's not just the depression it's
like i don't want to be i never was one
of them people that wanted to be rich
i just want to be comfortable i want a
place to call home
i
want
my kids to
forgive me one day or at least even if
they don't forgive me
i want to
explain
to them why
and i want to be sober when i do it
you know
it's
it's not the craziness like
it's
i'm i just you know
i love reading like like money don't
mean nothing to me
happiness does
like i can be happy picking up a book
and
going and stumping and sitting on the
hammocks and reading
like
i
i i just want to be comfortable like if
i want a coffee i'm just going to be
able to go in the store and buy coffee
like
that's it like
it has like
like these people like a lot of people
that i talk to like my my brother for
instance like
he not the brother with my children my
other brother is an addict and like
that's what he thinks life resolves
around his money
i had all that when i was younger i sold
the drugs did the internet pornography
this was before like i got on heroin
when i was still on xanax and like oxies
but
i had the clothes the cars like i had
that
what makes me happy is
knowing that i have someone that loves
me
that
like
we've been through thick and thin
together you know um
when we were like
we've had clean time together homeless
like we would ride the train if one
wanted to get high
the other would talk the man the other
one out of it like
like i know we can stay clean together
it's just gets so depressed and that you
just get to the point where you're like
you just want to get high just to forget
you know
andrew what would you say
is the most important thing you've
learned in your life
that you can't go back
but
you know
you can change you can go forward
you know you can't go back and you can't
change what you've done but you can
learn
and you can grow
and
if people don't want to forgive you
as long as i forgive myself
all right andrea thank you so much for
sharing your story and i wish you the
best of luck with wherever you go from
here thank you
sounds like you're trying to get on the
right path
i'm going to get on the right path [ __ ]
trying i'm doing it
good for you
all right thank you you're welcome
you